la región de hatay es la que más ha
sufrido el terremoto que ocurrió hace
justo una semana en el sureste de
Turquía al norte de Siria y aquí los
servicios sanitarios turcos están
absolutamente colapsados por eso la
ayuda internacional se ha desplegado en
este lugar aquí el gobierno español ha
colocado un hospital de campaña para
tratar a los heridos y pacientes dentro
de esa ciudad de Alejandrita es muy
importante que haya una atención
primaria porque es verdad que los
hospitales grandes ahora mismo o los
hospitales locales están colapsados con
pacientes que atendieron en los primeros
momentos del terremoto entonces hay
muchas personas desplazadas que no
tienen se han quedado sin vivienda y se
han quedado también sin sanidad no
tienen acceso y todo lo que nosotros
podamos evitar acá para que no llegue
allí pues es un es un además de por
supuesto un favor para los pacientes es
apoyar al sistema de salud local los
médicos españoles desplazados aquí nos
cuentan que tendrán que estar un mes de
misión en el que tratarán sobre todo ya
está ocurriendo ahora mismo personas con
enfermedades crónicas mujeres
embarazadas y patologías diversas sobre
todo lo es será así porque según nos
cuentan la mayoría de personas con
traumatologías derivadas del terremoto
ya ha sido tratada y esta gente viene
aquí o tiene que venir aquí porque no
existe casilla sanidad turca que está
siendo absolutamente colapsada nosotros
estamos preparados para tratar un
posible brote de cólera porque tenemos
digamos sobre todo
los elementos necesarios No sé no me
puedo aventurar si puede haber o no la
única posibilidad que veo ahora mismo es
que viniera gente de la otro lado de la
frontera no que actualmente sabemos que
está reportado que hay casos de cólera a
este a este otro a este lado no Y a
partir de ahí se pudiera transmitir el
el virus vaya o la bacteria es mucho más
complicado no porque cuando se produce
un como usted muy bien ha dicho un
trauma colectivo en la intensidad del
trauma Es mayor que cuando se produce a
nivel individual No porque se produce
digamos una especie como de contagio del
trauma Contagio del estrés que la gente
está viviendo Y eso acrecienta y es
mucho hace que sea mucho más intenso el
la patología propia los médicos de
españoles desplazados aquí nos cuentan
que la más importante ahora mismo es
tratar la emergencia que se ha creado
después del terremoto pero sin embargo
el reto más importante será dentro de
unos meses a conseguir acompañar Y
tratar a los decenas de miles incluso
cientos de miles de turcos que han sido
desplazados por culpa de ese terremoto